el diodo es un semiconductor muy
importante y cualquier otro dispositivo
semiconductor viene de alguna
combinación de diodos en esta imagen
puedes ver un diodo es un diodo que
sería fácil de adquirir y observa el
diodo es un pequeño tubo de vidrio con
una longitud aproximada de 4 milímetros
puedes ver que dentro de éste hay un
chip de silicio hecho para actuar como
un diodo entonces a todo esto viene la
pregunta qué es un diodo
un diodo se encarga de conducir
corriente en una dirección pero no en la
otra el símbolo que utilizamos para un
diodo se mira de esta forma tiene esta
forma una flecha que indica la corriente
de avance esto es lo que indica esta
flecha y ahora vamos a etiquetar el
voltaje del diodo de esta manera
muy bien
y ahora vamos a entender cómo funciona
un diodo para esto voy a dibujar una
curva y ve para un diodo y supongamos
que el diodo fuera perfecto funcionará
perfectamente y en la dirección de
retroceso el voltaje del diodo fuera
negativo es decir esta terminal tuviera
un voltaje más alto que esta terminal
eso querría decir que no hay corriente
fluyendo y para cualquier voltaje
positivo tendríamos esto por lo que
-dijo- dow estaría actuando como un
cable este será nuestro modelo cero así
lo vamos a nombrar ahora en la vida real
un diodo no se comporta de esta manera
vamos a ver el modelo de un diodo de
silicio a este modelo le vamos a poner
modelo número uno un diodo de silicio se
conduce a un voltaje un poco positivo y
después sube este voltaje es aproximado
a 0.6 volts este resulta un buen modelo
y vende un diodo y también resulta como
un buen modelo para muchos circuitos
simples que construimos anteriormente
ahora recuerda lo siguiente
cuando teníamos la curva y veloz
resistor es estas curvas se miraban un
poco así una recta que atravesaba por el
cero con pendiente constante ajá y
observa la diferencia entre estas dos
curvas la curva y ve del diodo y la
curva y b de los resistor es ajá puedes
ver que la de él la del diodo es no
lineal ahora veamos el siguiente modelo
vamos con el modelo número 2 este modelo
representa el diodo más usado ajá este
es el modelo que usarás cuando simule
circuitos o diodos entonces supongamos
tener un diodo así y se nos pide la
curva y ve que lo representa
entonces para esto lo que necesitamos es
encontrar una especie de caja que cree
voltaje es decir un suministro de
energía que pueda ajustarse de cierta
forma y también necesitaría algún
artefacto que lea la intensidad de
corriente como un amperímetro
el amperímetro y este suministro de
energía
estarían conectados
y bueno así haríamos mediciones para
generar la curva y ve entonces bueno
iniciamos con cero en b
y si en efecto iniciar en cero todo
estaría bien porque si no iniciar en
cero eso qué quiere decir quiere decir
que esto está generando energía lo cual
no va a ser
ahora vamos a suponer que yo estoy
girando poco a poco el botón de ajuste
para el voltaje y notar que mientras voy
girando no hay corriente en 0.1 volts en
0.2 tampoco en 0.3 y cuando llega a 0.6
volts en el diodo aquí es vd aquí esta
vez de más menos cuando el voltaje en el
diodo está en aproximadamente 0.6 volts
notaré que la corriente sube a 5000
amperes luego sube un poco más a 10.000
amperes y así sucesivamente y yo puedo
calcular estos puntos en la curva ahora
si yo cambio el voltaje aplicando un
voltaje negativo al diodo invierto el
orden y me sitúe en el lado izquierdo de
la gráfica y b es decir voy a estar
viendo en esta dirección en el eje del
voltaje mi amperímetro leerá 0 milián
pérez porque el valor de la corriente
que circula en el sentido inverso es
cercano a 0 ligeramente negativo debajo
del eje del voltaje si el caso fuera que
yo hiciera este voltaje un número muy
grande pero un negativo
es decir un valor negativo a tal
magnitud como por ejemplo menos 50 volts
y eso eso fuera este punto de aquí lo
que se vería es un incremento muy brusco
de corriente así observa este repentino
cambio aquí en esta línea esta línea va
a seguir hacia abajo y a esto se le
llama voltaje de ruptura y se abrevia b
br ahora un voltaje de ruptura típico en
diodos ordinarios es de menos 50 volts
observa esta gráfica muestra dos
rupturas aquí en menos dos volts en esta
escala en menos dos volts hay una luego
viajamos a la izquierda hasta llegar a
menos 50 bolsa y ocurre esta ruptura
ahora la mayoría de las veces usamos
diodos con terminales entre uno positivo
y uno negativo y así es como conocemos
la característica y vez de un diodo
muy bien esta parte de la curva puede
ser modelada con una ecuación que se vea
así
esta es la ecuación y ve de un diodo
y se representa por y es igual a y s
que simboliza la corriente de saturación
multiplicada por la q que simboliza la
carga en el electrón nkoulou
multiplicada por b que simboliza el
voltaje del diodo dividido entre k t
donde k es la constante de boltzmann y t
es la temperatura la medida respecto al
cero absoluto de kelvin menos 1 esa es
la ecuación ive para un diodo esta
ecuación representa esta parte de la
curva para un diodo y de hecho es una
ecuación que representa perfectamente un
diodo de verdad ahora vamos a analizar
cada una de las partes de la ecuación
entonces primero y ese es la corriente
de saturación
un valor típico para y ese en silicio es
de 10 a la menos 12 amperes y eso es
igual a un pico amper ese es el valor de
iese ahora q es la carga del electrón
que es igual a 1.602 por 10 a la menos
19 colomos
muy bien bebé es el voltaje del diodo
acá que es una minúscula es la constante
de boltzmann que es igual a 1.38 por 10
a la menos 23 jules porque el fin
te simboliza la temperatura medida en
que levin con una k mayúscula
y es medida con respecto al cero
absoluto en kelvin una temperatura de
cero absoluto en que el vino 0 k
corresponde a menos 273 grados celsius
eso es muy frío ahora esto es la
ecuación de la curva y ve del diodo
tiene este término exponencial y observa
la gráfica tal vez tú digas bueno yo no
le veo forma de exponencial a esta curva
pero es solo por culpa de la escala del
dibujo baja entonces lo que haré es
acercarme mucho al origen y veremos cómo
este término exponencial se muestra en
la gráfica y también veremos cuál es el
significado de iese entonces voy a
escribir nuevamente la ecuación
y es igual a y ese que multiplica ha
elevado a cuba
sobre cat
- 1
y en esta imagen de la curva y ved el
diodo me acerque mucho al origen como
puedes ver nos hemos acercado en una
escala aproximada de 10 entonces el eje
de los bolts puedes ver que aquí está
una décima de un volt ajá está muy muy
cerca de esta escala y la escala de la
corriente ha sido también ampliada a un
buen número de veces ahora está en pico
amperes está a 10 a la menos 12 am pérez
en lugar de 10 a la menos 3 amperes y
puedes ver que ahora sí se parece esto a
una curva exponencial
ajá puedes ver una pequeña corriente
negativa y ese que aparece cuando el
diodo está en polarización inversa aquí
el voltaje es negativo
esta cantidad de aquí esto
y ese corriendo en dirección inversa del
diodo ahora observa la ecuación del
diodo haz que sea un número negativo y
lo que va a pasar es que este término de
la ecuación será muy pequeño comparado
con 1 y entonces te quedará y ese por 1
y eso es lo que se ve aquí
esta es una corriente muy pequeña puedes
ver que en la escala está en el área por
debajo de los picos amperes y en la
mayoría de los casos puedes ignorar esta
corriente puede suponer que es 0 ahora
en el próximo vídeo vamos a usar un
diodo o en un circuito y resolveremos
circuitos que incluyan a estos diodos no
lineales